you move towards something if it
animates your life
exactly if you're doing something for
other people all the time you're going
to feel there's a deficit that you're
something's out of sync I've said this
before sometimes because we have lived
so much as actors where we are pleasing
or trying to get it right or hit the
mark or say the line and that is so much
about it can be so much about what
someone else needs from us what the time
is what the director needs what the
writers need we got to get it in on time
I sometimes will do like no one's
looking first very pretend there's
nobody around like what is it
what would you like to do right now just
very quietly on the shoulder like what
and it'd be like I think I would like to
do this for a little while and learning
to like fan that fire of
what would be if what would be helpful
right now in this moment